1997 photo j'ai une bonne tête de
vainqueur mais nous étions 19e rang
desquels à jarratt an tout pile 20 ans
quand vous avez 20 ans la whey mes
frères tu avais 20 ans tableaux dont
google la boîte à 5,5 comme un cadeau
cadeaux pour vous j'ai 25 ans dont 95
[Applaudissements]
julien série k way avec nous absolument
je devais travailler avec nous
maintenant
dans cette photo c'est pas ça vous fait
de cadeaux plus mignon c'est une photo
je démarrais la télévision donc elle
doit dater de 97 ans
[Applaudissements]
le pied bot le pied bondira boulou un
gars patinent bien sûr manille en
différé des pitbulls ou non mais s'en
est mêlée cibray
elle est belle et le mollet et
magnifique à trimolet vous avez une
belle prime time oui c'est nassim et
recel et non exécutive chez c'était dans
un nouveau demeure maintenant à la même
photo masse encore jamais ramené une
photo j'ai oublié sa 90 noir et blanc ou
non à l'abricot république mois ou plus
basses et fermé les ch'tis glace mais je
dis la vérité maintenant si on pète est
cent fois mieux maintenant non mais si
on est bien dans morita sion paris-dakar
en mauritanie à nouakchott
ah oui il faisait quoi là-bas j'étais
reporter à françois je suivais le paris
dakar ce qu'on a du mal à croire quitté
reporter tout voyage non mais si oui
franchement franchement aujourd'hui
trace d'accord me dis pas que tu avais
la cote avec 7 t non pas spécialement
ils étaient mariés puis c'est pour ça
qu'on se marier comme ça on est
tranquille vous je sais même pas si j'ai
envie de voir devrait pas très belle oui
c'est une photo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai beau être georges là on était très
bien sûr vote au niveau de la vanne
c'est le problème que tu as tu vois
c'est oui dit mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé alors nous sommes en 1992 je suis
en train de suivre le tour de france il
fait chaud mais un chapeau ah ouais à
chacun de tirer le chapeau en fait il
est il plaint on dirait une qui par
l'impression que c'est flou d' une
partie de ton corps mais ouais c'est
vrai ça on dirait contact pour dire
écoute à col et un corps moi j'en ai
envoyé deux une deux mois en 89 ou 90 je
sais plus je suis triste parce que je
pense oui 18,5 quand un disque
[Applaudissements]
elle est aimée c'est quoi cette nouvelle
c'est pas elle et je n'avais minutes
avec mon fils non mais je préfère ça à
huawei écosse remettez l'autre parce que
away mais franchement vous êtes
magnifique oui j'en rigolais fenêtre
avoir été mais pas toujours aussi belle
je vous le dis tous les jours et des
délires différents la la ça car les
plongeant là on a une autre coiffure un
autre délire c'est tout mon coeur et mes
16 ans sur cette photo avec leur
meilleure amie à l'époque les mêmes
procédés lui on monte on descend il a
pas
il n'a pas fait partie des meubles
importés et n'attendez warda partie non
non non aimer les deux réunions devaient
déjà nouvelles poutres pas mal elle est
plus basse que c'est non mais c'est une
blague
franchement ça c'est une blague mobilier
a dit mme maillet alors on dans les
années 90 xavier quel âge 22 ans 22 ans
elle a alors fait
[Applaudissements]
mais vous avez mis de l'huile sur votre
candidate ou pas du beurre de lui vous
allez faire des très rares
elle a salué jeudi alors que tu es
maintenant pour le dogue allemand
j'étais à new york il faudra qu'ils
s'appellent caréna tyra termina 3e et
c'était un spécial neuf semaines allait
être un petit peu à l'oreille journée
secte est exceptionnel et canal qu'est
ce qu'elle est belle
merci aller à l'analyse de l'école n'ont
aucun onishi mme jean luc lhemanne on
arrive ça va ça veut dire pour lui parce
que je veux pas passer sans annuler la
non non non il ya toujours été bonne on
ne peut pas dire on va voir
[Applaudissements]
foot l uci mais moi aussi j'adore quoi
c'est pas vrai mais en visite chez tim
pour le voc bretons comptent les équipes
basques ont bossé mais arrêter avec
cette surprise à chaque fois que vous
vous trouvez pas trop j'avais 20 ans et
je vous dis en vérité j'étais parti en
vacances avec mon meilleur pote
sébastien sera qui je bosse encore way
et adore le dernier jour des vacances on
s'est dit on n'a fait aucune photo donc
on a fait en 2 heures toutes les photos
de l'actrice aurait plaidé pour des
pauses comme ça faussement naturel et
jean rolin telle époque de top gun et
j'adore quand on voit les côtes comme ça
va chez le boucher
[Applaudissements]